hi oh yeah got involved if you want me
to drive you we gotta go no personal
chauffeur going works okay seriously dad
walking would have been fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day
again spider-man this guy swings in once
the day's zip zap zop dancing guys don't
cops run red lights oh you're some dude
but uh not your dad
in your universe there's only one
spider-man but there's another universe
it looks this sounds like yours but it's
not my name is Miles Morales
thank you you like me I knew my day
would come around this time I know it's
complicated
wanna know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man I love this
burger so delicious the best burgers
I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about saving
the world you have to think about saving
one person one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
I see the spark in you it's amazing pack
up whatever you choose to do it that
you'll be great
I love you moms you gotta say I love you
dad I love you
when did you teach me that I didn't it's
a little joke team-building hey guys
okay who are you i'm gwen stacy people
are there senator comic-con what's
coming hey everybody its charlie we got
a whole bunch of new spider-man to break
down if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's a new round of that
infinity war DBZ giveaway going on all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video we found out we're getting
spider-gwen we found out we're getting
kingpin ultimate goblin in a bunch of
the voice actors were confirmed so the
first big thing Jake Johnson is playing
Peter Parker you could see he's an older
version of the character there's
actually a really cool Easter Egg when
he's looking at his suits here this one
here on the right is from secret war in
2004 not to be confused with Secret Wars
which we've been talking about relative
to infinity war in the live-action
universe secret war was sort of like a
Captain America smaller Avengers team-up
where they went to battle lucci of von
barda's who had taken over for Doctor
Doom who had been trapped in hell so it
was sort of like a smaller version of
Secret Wars within Latveria the one on
the left is the electro proof suit it
does exactly what it sounds like it's
built for fighting villains like electro
most of you probably know a version of
Miles Morales origin story he got the
same spider bite that Peter got but it
was from a spider that his uncle had
boosted from a special lab his uncle is
the Prowler who shows up during the
trailer fighting spider-man the thing is
as they show you a lot of spider-man
fighting some of these villains like he
saves miles from the ultimate Goblin but
most of you know the rest of miles his
origin story is is that he's only
inspired to put on the costume after
Peter gets killed by the ultimate Goblin
so then Myles goes up against ultimate
Goblin and ultimately takes him down but
they haven't confirmed who's playing
ultimate goblin I don't know if it's
going to be Norman Osborn or if they've
changed it
I don't know why they would change that
from the comics but they've only
confirmed that Liev Schreiber is playing
the kingpin we saw a whole bunch of Fisk
name drops in the last trailer so this
just confirms that and he actually shows
up during the trailer we see at least at
the beginning of the story miles his
father is still alive he's deceased
during most of the story he's just being
raised by his mother and kind of his
uncle but his uncle is a criminal as the
Prowler so obviously he winds up having
to take him down so you do see him
chasing him through the trailer he talks
about different worlds so I'm wondering
how crazy they are going to get with
genuine spider verse because
spider verse is like a multiversal story
so I think because this is animated they
can have a little more fun with it and
it sounds like based on the narration
from Jake Johnson's Peter Parker
he's been spider-man for a long time had
a lot of adventures with the Avengers
but because he says he doesn't have any
cash and he kind of seems like he's on
his own like I'm not expecting all the
other Avengers to pop up in this I'm
just wondering what his timeline is in
this universe if they're just doing
genuine Ultimates universe continuity
but because a lot of the characters that
are dead when miles become spider-man in
the comics are alive in this trailer I'm
wondering if they're gonna compress the
timeline and he'll learn from spider-man
he'll meet spider-gwen and learn about
the spider verse then Peter dies then
his father dies and that sort of serves
as miles as big called action like I
have to make my neighborhood better and
become the friendly neighborhood
spider-man of his area of town the cool
thing about this dropping at Christmas
is that they'll have finished filming
the live-action spider-man homecoming 2
movie so I'm hoping that they attached
the first teaser for that to this but I
know there's the big question about that
marketing the next spider-man movie
while he's still supposed to be dead
during Avengers infinity war but because
we'll have already gotten the Captain
Marvel teaser I'm hoping that they will
have already said what the title for
Avengers 4 is way before we ever get to
December so that will have an idea for
what's going on and it makes it a little
bit easier for Sony to market the next
spider-man movie because that's all on
them like Sony decides how they're going
to drop that spider-man trailer Marvel
is doing all their Avengers 4 stuff do
you know two completely separate
entities when it comes to marketing the
films a lot of you have asked me about
the rumor that the title is going to
be spider-man field trip it's totally
possible I mean that does sound legit
but it's not quite as clicky as I would
expect a spider-man movie titled to be
so I wouldn't be surprised if they
change it to something a little bit
different but it'll be a Spider Man
subtitle it won't be spider-man 2 but
just let me know in the comments what
you think of this so far in the fact
that if they're doing spider-gwen where
you want them to take it next the only
spider-man I'm not expecting to see
would be like the iron spider version
just because they're doing that in the
live-action movies right now and I don't
think they want to step on each other's
toes but I think part of the idea is is
in success yeah I mean if this movie
does well they will continue to do
sequels and you'll just build out into
the larger spider verse so you'll deal
with bigger villains they could work
their way up to more Lund because he's a
genuine multiversal villian but
obviously they're gonna start with the
initial big ultimate spider-man villains
so ultimate goblin kingpin really good
places to start what will happen is is
they're supposed to be How to Train Your
Dragon 3 trailer later today so if I
have time I'll do a video for that but I
also have an Avengers 4 video that I'm
working on two for special new artwork
how funny is it though that spider-gwen
is Hailee Steinfeld who we just got done
watching in the bumblebee trailer click
here for that and click here for more
new avengers thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]